[Music]
your former Daily Show correspondent of
course are you still keeping up with
politics yes I do
I do you can't help but keep up with
politics but I mean where do you get
your info I um I like to get my info
from the streets I came here to the
streets while getting humped oh yeah
okay keep it near I just got some good
information from a taco truck oh you're
being serious I totally am serious I
think you know Trump's got a lot of
problems right now it's his written
answers yeah another thing coming out
hopefully yeah and and he's got his
problems with Mexico and Mexico and you
may have a problem he's not even aware
of I was at a taco truck and I was
waiting for the guy to finish up his
order in front of me and I overheard
what you saying goes hey bro
on that order can I get most Elantra cuz
you heard what they're doing to the
cilantro right the guy in the taco truck
cause see see I know it walks away
leaving me standing there going on
excuse me
[Laughter]
and that guy goes Oh bro my mom told me
not to eat any cilantro if it's from
Mexico cuz they're [ __ ] in it what
to get back at Trump yeah what yeah
totally and I I just said I had the same
reaction I go but don't get me wrong
buddy I'm all for a good Trump takedown
but not a collateral damage in the ship
a lot of people they get one guy totally
it really doesn't fly that there's some
ocean's 11 style planning taking place
in a Mexican cilantro field that level
of organization you really think they're
putting a lot of thought into this yeah
totally
alright everyone gather round gather
round not sure you heard today but
Donald Trump is done in the game not
only did he call all the people crossing
the border rapist not only is he kicked
and beloved newscaster Jorge Ramos out
of a press conference in Iowa saying go
back to Univision in a tone that implies
go back to Mexico but now he's comparing
Mexico to China at an alarming rate
we're gonna do something about it we're
gonna do something about it here no idea
is a bad idea
don't edit yourself yeah yeah I say we
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
but that is taco bowl yeah do you really
think this is happening
I certainly hope not because I love
cilantro so much right yeah you when you
order did you order with no cilantro
right absolutely hear that story and
then say yeah that sounds pretty
interesting I'll double up on this a lot
I took my chances with the cilantro
you